hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
commentary walkthrough for candy crush
soda level 250 this is a problem this is
a problem level for a lot of people and
it's been holding people up ever since
it came out so making some amendments
and tips to this version of the video I
just played so that get a better idea of
what you need to do so this is a layer
above the string one we have three bears
so the first room is pretty simple we
just want to get through it as fast as
we possibly can
got to pop the bottles so we can get the
soda up high enough and most of the time
this one won't be the one that gives you
trouble but you do want to you know just
concentrate on trying to make some
specials get some things moving around
and that way you can get through it
before too long
so you can see I've busted out the
middle kind of naturally and now I can
not have a little bit more room to make
matches and all I'm gonna do basically
is just pop another bottle and then the
bear can move up once I get rid of that
that blocker there so obviously a strike
plus raft is always good on this type of
level causes a lot of damage and gets
things cascading in the direction we
want them to and here we can make just a
fish we'll be able to get us across
there you go so we have 35 moves left
that's not bad we didn't really get
stuck and now this slow this board is
one that can really drive you nuts the
trick here is to and you'll see you see
that I'm doing it right now you want to
kind of get the Cascade going at the top
as you're matching your way underneath
the bear and see how that's taking out
some of the honey as we go I found that
was the best way I had to play this a
couple times to beat it and it won't
always work as smooth as it does here
but that's that's what I tried to do
each time and eventually I got past it
so you know don't worry about trying to
pop the bear out at the top or move them
over or anything like that just sort of
keep working below look for combos and
then try to leave something down here if
you can for whenever he finally gets
loose like here you know if we had a
striped candy below and it would go
right out and get him above but once the
once you're all the way at the end on
the side there you can see that he'll
come down either
as a cascades so this board here is it
just gives me a headache looking at it
we got ice like it's thicker as you go
gonna definitely need some help up some
good combos here again strike + wraps
which we'll get right here kind of pay
attention because there are wrapped
candies under the ice so if you can use
those as you come down for combos
that'll be a big big boost from when
you're stuck wrapped candies are good
because they'll hit the ice twice if you
can get a you know color bomb plus a
wrapped that's gonna that's really gonna
move you up on the board and any other
combo that involves a raft is gonna be
ideal we also you know bears or sorry
fish with color bombs would be great
because that'll do a lot of damage to a
lot of ice and I moved I accidentally
moved the bear over one I kind of try to
like to move them straight in the middle
so Oh I'll move him back over like that
happened if I get a chance to do that so
right now we got eight moves so things
are getting a little bit tougher color
bomb match here so hopefully we can use
that for a combo
I have been playing well a striped
collar will be good too I've been
playing the newer level so I got used to
having sprinkled shell again so when I
was playing this I kept wanting to you
know get him going but there you go so
there you see that we have you know once
you can what you can get a you know
enough space in the ice and you can you
know make a combo you'll be able to get
the bear through there it seems
impossible a lot of times but you know
just try to try to try to you know do
the things I said conserve moves in the
first room get out as fast as you can in
the second room work at the bottom get
the Cascade to work for you and then in
the third room you just really need to
concentrate on making a big combo and
things will eventually work out for you
so I hope this helped please like the
video if you found it helpful please
subscribe to my channel I'm the only
person who makes these types of videos
and I make them all the time so make
sure you follow and check us out I'll be
making some more new new one soon yeah
but if you have a question leave a
comment and I'll see you soon bye